Well, Sam, I want to say thank you. I feel like I've learned a lot
and I have built a really cool app,
and it's on my phone. that's pretty exciting.
>> Yeah.
>> I guess, all that stuff we learned about. All the workflows, the
approvals, the, you know, dashboards and charts. Is that all in the phone too?
>> Yeah. So everything we built today is totally accounted
for and works both in the desktop or mobile app.
>> Cool.
>> So you simultaneously
built two apps today.
>> That's really awesome. I guess my last
question is where do I go from here?
I mean, I'm hooked. I'm into this. I want to build more stuff. What should I do?
So I mean, we've only scratched the surface
of stuff that you can do with point and
click tools, so you can learn a little
bit more about what else we could do there.
>> Mm-hm. you could maybe read about Apex and Visual Force,
and you know, get into the programmatic code side of things.
>> Okay. Or you could take the
skills that we've learned today and then build your app. What do you want to do?
>> Let's do that. I want to build another app. Alright, let's do it.
>> Congratulations. You created an app and you went mobile. It's pretty
exciting. But really, it's just the tip of the iceberg, there's so
much more you can do in Salesforce. I'm really excited to see
what you're going to do in your final project. Are you ready to start?